CBS News legal analyst Ricky Kleeman
joins us at the table good morning -
morning so much to sort through you know
Jeff is telling me there was a big gasp
in the courtroom when Sean Hannity's
name was revealed and last night on his
show he seemed to be having a what had
happened was moment but when we look at
all of this what weather sean hannity
was a client or not is really not the
crux of this story right here no it's
not I think the thing that's interesting
about Sean Hannity is more interesting
to us as journalists because it is
highly unethical for him to rail against
this raid of Michael Cohen's office when
he knows that he's been a person who at
least has contacted Michael Cohen for
legal advice or real estate advice so
there may be documents that were seized
that are sean hannity's how could you
possibly go on air and not disclose that
so what was an issue and we hear this
phrase attorney-client privilege thrown
around by everyone would you sort that
for us what is and what is an attorney
class I would be happy to do that
because there has been so much
misinformation on TV about this the
attorney-client privilege is abundantly
clear if a person seeks legal advice
from a lawyer and the lawyer
communicates with that person what they
say or what documents they may exchange
as a communication about legal advice is
privileged now when does the privilege
go away well if there's the third party
in the room if they disclose the
information to someone else they've
waived the privilege but most important
here if the documents because we're
talking about documents here or any
communication is involved in a crime or
fraud where the lawyer is involved the
privilege is pierced it is gone and of
course that's what's at issue any sort
of at least temporary win for Michael
Cohen in the sense that I know they
wanted to go through all of the
documents seized themselves the judge
said no the prosecutors wanted a tape
team to come in the judge said no to
that either the judge said that you're
gonna have a special master come in
perhaps tell us what a special master is
what we have here is really delay what
we have from Kimball wood is a judge is
to say she is going to consider what
they're a tane team from the government
or a special master we'll review these
documents meanwhile the government
indexes them digitally they give them a
copy of that to Michael Cohen so he'll
be happy
but Michael Cohen and president Trump
are not going to decide what is
privileged here ultimately either a
tainting a special master and a court
will make that decision
Western Oh was it a win for Michael
Cohen back to her question yesterday
partial partial he gets delay delay
delay delay always a win of the
defendant or the tark I'm sure he will
take it even if it's all Ricky thank you